Irish eyes will be smiling on you if you throw this great St. Patty's Day party.
You will need: invitations, corned beef, cabbage and potatoes...
...or other traditional Irish foods, guacamole, green salsa and or spinach dip,...
...ingredients for an Irish soda bread, green M&Ms and jelly beans,...
...green, orange and white paper goods and decorations, lots of beer,...
...green food dye, vodka, sour apple schnapps and sweet and sour mix for apple martinis,...
...Irish music, a CD or DVD of Riverdance, a rabbit's foot, coffee, whisky and whipped cream.
Optional: Four heart-shaped cake pans, Granny Smith apples and oranges.
Step one: Send out invitations a few weeks in advance.
Decorate them with shamrocks, leprechauns, rainbows and or pots of gold...
...or simply print them on green paper.
Step two: Plan the menu.
Corned beef and cabbage is traditional but feel free to serve something else...
...like a hearty Irish stew made with lamb, not beef, or fish and chips, chips being french fries.
Include some crowd-pleasing appetizers that happen to be green...
...like guacamole, green salsa and spinach dip.
Step three: Make Irish soda bread or bake a four-leaf clover cake by using four heart-shaped pans.
Put out bowls of green M&Ms and or green jelly beans.
Step four: The Irish flag is green, white and orange...
...so keep those colors in mind when you pick up paper goods, candles, balloons, streamers, etc.
Float some green and orange tea candles in glass bowls of water,...
...or, for an unusual look, in martini glasses.
A bowl of oranges and Granny Smith apples makes a nice and practical centerpiece.
Step five: Make green beer by adding a few drops of green food coloring to a pale-colored brew.
Make apple martinis for non-beer drinkers using sour apple schnapps,...
...vodka, sweet and sour mix and apple slice garnishes.
Step six: Play music by Irish artists like The Chieftains, U2, Enya, The Corrs and Van Morrison.
Step seven: Pop in a CD or DVD of Riverdance and hold an Irish step dancing contest.
Present a rabbit's foot, a symbol of good luck in Ireland, to the winner.
Step eight: Serve everyone an Irish coffee,...
...coffee with whisky and topped with whipped cream, before they leave.
Did you know: The oldest official St. Patrick's Day parade...
...is the one held in New York City which started in 1762.